let's turn our attention to women's
soccer where Megan rapino you know Megan
rapino she's a left-wing activist who I
think uh coincidentally also plays
soccer Megan rapino has a novel argument
as to why God does not exist and the
argument comes because in Megan
Rino's final match of her
career uh she was injured and so she
didn't get to finish her match and she
said this was was greatly unfair and
proof that God does not
exist before we get to Megan's argument
I have to
ask how many times is this woman going
to retire from soccer because I I saw
this headline and I said wait a second
Megan rapino is still playing soccer I
distinctly remember months ago reading
that Megan rapino had played her last
match and something went wrong in that
too and she was whining about that she
was complaining about whatever happened
in that game and then I said okay well
she's whining and complaining and she's
a very difficult woman to listen to but
hey at least she is done with soccer and
I don't need to read about her anymore
and her Antics and her anti-American
activism but then months later I have to
read about Megan rapino again so I
looked I said oh this was her last game
too but I turns out I was right because
I looked up this is the same news source
this is ABC News September 25th what
happened at Megan Rino's final Us wnt
game Team USA scored a victory against
South Africa in Rino's final game
September 25th ino's final game then ABC
News November 11th Megan rapino exits
nwsl Championship with injury in final
game how many final games is this woman
going to have can can this be the final
final one please if we if we had enough
Megan rapino I certainly
have right after she makes her argument
as to why God does not exist which we
will get to right after I tell you about
beam Organics right now go to shop beam
beam.com are you struggling to sleep at
night did you know that poor sleep can
cause weight gain mood issues poor
mental health and lowered productivity
sleep is the foundation of our mental
and physical health and performance you
must have a consistent nighttime routine
to function at your best if you're
struggling with sleep you got to go
check out Beam Beam is designed to help
you fall asleep stay asleep and wake up
refreshed beam's dream powder not only
Rhymes it contains a powerful allnatural
blend of ingredients including magnesium
L theanine they sent some dream down to
the studio for our team to try
apparently the team stole all of it
already cuz I haven't even gotten to
have a nice extra heaping helping of
beam and beam is helping people fall
asleep stay asleep unlike regular
sleeping pills that will make you wake
up feeling groggy beam will help you
wake up ready to go just mix beam dream
into hot water or milk yum stir and
froth and enjoy it before bedtime and
today our listeners can get a special
discount on beam's delicious dream
powder they're best selling hot cocoa
for sleep with no added sugar they have
flavors like cinnamon cocoa chocolate
peanut butter better sleep has never
tasted better go check out their
bestselling dream powder take advantage
of their biggest sale of the Year get up
to 50% % off for a limited time beam
right now shop beam.com kwes your
discount is auto applied at checkout no
code is necessary bam M that's the name
of the company go to shop
beam.com for up to 50% off right now go
to pre-born docomo little things can
make a big difference a little note a
little smile a precious little baby when
you sponsor an ultrasound at pre-born
your gift no matter how small makes a
big difference in a big way who will
this little baby become what life will
this baby live how about the mother who
was spared from unspeakable sorrow
because of you a small donation of just
28 bucks gives a mother the opportunity
to meet her child through ultrasound
which could help double a baby's chance
at life all you've got to do is take a
few minutes today to make a life-saving
donation pre-born will take it from
there pre-born network of clinics
rescues 200 tiny babies every day simple
as that they also fund raise separately
for their administrative costs so every
dollar you give is going directly
towards saving babies and they get
results 200 every day it's very simple
the mother gets an ultrasound doubles
the chance that she will not have an
abortion this is a very simple effective
way to do your part to help save
innocent little babies get involved
today by dialing pound 250 say keyword
baby or go to pre-com nesc wle that is
pre-worn
dcoms at long last here is Megan Rino's
argument as to why God does not exist
this is a long one although I'm gonna
get the Aaron Rogers treatment whatever
that is um so I'm gonna be calling him
or whoever did his surgery because we
need to speed this up but yeah I thought
about a little bit I mean you know I'm
not a religious person or anything and
if there wasn't God like this is proof
that there isn't this is up um
so yeah it just it's just guys six
minutes in eat my KES I mean
what so the argument let's take it she's
obviously being tongue and cheek here
but the argument is an argument that a
lot of Reddit tier atheists make which
is because a bad thing happened to me
that's proof that God does not exist but
you know this is an old problem that
people have been grappling with for uh
ever and it's theodicy it's the problem
of pain and suffering given a God who is
om omnipotent and Omni benevolent and
omnipresent uh some people I think have
pointed to this as a great example a
great counterargument to the argument
that Megan rapino thinks she's making
the fact that this woman who in her
public life is quite odious uh was not
able to play what I hope is her final
game of soccer uh
might not be seen as proof that God does
not exist some would actually come to
quite the opposite conclusion here but
even if one did
not uh it Bears repeating because
because one can understand it
intellectually but when you actually do
rip your Achilles when you're playing
your last game and it's really
meaningful to you you act you actually
will cry out to God very often and be
very angry with God even faithful people
will do that very often so I have a bit
of sympathy for Megan rapino here
but when you think about it
intellectually and you remove yourself
from the immediate pain of it uh you can
see it all quite clearly suffering is
not a proof against God's existence
because suffering has no moral quality
in and of itself it is the reaction to
suffering that has a moral quality and
the reaction to suffering can be one
that is degrading and is uh vicious or
the reaction to suffering can be
edifying and sanctifying and you can
come out strong whatever doesn't kill
you makes you stronger would be a
shallow way to put it and that's the
case and why is there sin and death in
the world because man has Free Will and
abused his free will to rebel against
God and as a consequence of that sin and
death pervade the world and and there
are Eternal consequences for sin but
there are also temporal effects of sin
so when you commit a sin you can you can
go and as it says in the gospel you can
go and confess your sins and the uh
successors to the apostles can forgive
your sins they can give you absolution
uh and and that takes care of the
Eternal consequences of sin but there's
still temporal consequences of sin if
you go out and steal a candy bar and
then you go and you say I'm sorry I
apologize you know God forgive me please
and then you receive Absolution from God
well the shop owner is still out of
candy bar he's still add a couple of
bucks there's still a temporal effect of
that and uh so sin and death pervade the
world beautifully uh described by John
Milton in Paradise Lost and but the the
happy ending to that is that uh there's
a solution and there's actually
Redemption that comes through suffering
and ultimately through the suffering of
the perfect victim who's totally
innocent and that's why we say on Easter
oh happy fault that won for us so great
So Glorious a redeemer so probably
probably a more in-depth answer than
Megan rapino was looking for but since
that is her final game of soccer I hope
I figured it would be good opportunity
to give it to her man what a great clip
that was it was good huh now make sure
hey you got to ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael nlls podcast we'll see
you next time